ah guys I'm trying this new look with my
eye makeup I'm calling it slightly more
elegant morning-after or I fell asleep
with my eye makeup on and this is how it
looks this morning also I'm not wearing
these intentionally well I guess tonight
why am I trying to prove myself to you
this is just what's up I don't feel like
doing my hair so I'm drying it like this
I'm going to a thing later and wait and
I figure it'll look crimped and like I
tried oh I know I'm trying too hard to
seem like I'm not try the story of
YouTube hey guys it's Tuesday erode its
grace and it's time to talk back to you
so let's start on Twitter it's weird
when you caress your own face yeah where
are the tweets and also the streets and
the tweets living the energy life why
did I choose this name I didn't look at
it all the way a new person you puts me
first and probably they don't know that
when new person comes I need my social
media I praise the crap out of them and
welcome to like Nate's grace Finn how do
I know it's a new person I don't know I
just guess live in the MiG life more
like but you should change your social
media handle because it sometimes is
awkward for other people to say it out
loud how about that but you seem like
you have good intentions I don't know Oh
Bryce I love how the whole turning
defendants come together to stop people
pirate in Captain Koda yes you guys have
been so great you know are doing like
Internet citizens arrests which is the
only thing Tim and I my brother and I
have ever wanted to do in life is
citizen arrest someone and you guys are
now getting into Internet citizen arrest
people so I'm jealous calm slash me
police only our new person new birth new
person at least only I'm really cool
easily
you got a lot of holes in your body
boo-boos
your French is actually pretty good
smiley face you must be led deaf because
my friend just let poor blip terribly
and it's okay I'm fine with it okay why
we wait you want a new person in person
okay why we wait do one do more like if
you put a white jelly on your way week
you two of you are gonna have a one-two
punch of fun Group a price cap Dakota
was amazing I was so sad when the film
ended sorry guys I mean our first draft
of the film was three thousand pages so
we just had to for a popular opinion cut
it down but one day you know we're all
hoping eventually we'll be able to put
out the 12 hour movie and really change
the landscape of film now let's go to
tumblr still feels terrible great
[ __ ] how big new person to person to
person grace [ __ ] out like more like
don't [ __ ] your own last name just love
it don't [ __ ] it up roars yes you did
not let of Kentico know what deleted to
work you got things are great get those
internet citizens are us I'm very happy
that you guys exists and you have all
come together to be just just like a
giant [ __ ] block you Potter's sincerely
Maddie to person to person to person
sincerely Maddie more like sincerely I'm
going bad hear that noise
I'm friendship the missus inside man
you're a boy can we get nachos
only if you don't have sex with someone
else
comedian is my favorite that's a joke
from the movie you again and if you
bought the movie legally on Camp Takota
calm and then downloaded it and didn't
pirate it and put it up on another
website and just enjoyed it because you
appreciate the fact that some people in
the world tried to work really hard and
come together to make art for you and
that you can enjoy in your life that
doesn't cost you really anything other
than the price for the movie and has
cost us all a lot of our time and energy
but it's all for the greater good now
let's go to youtube doesn't feel any
better
DeeDee Downey new person to person to
person did you down any more like
designated driver down in the county
your Brides like you lady you
transphobic piece of [ __ ] okay yeah I
want to do really very quickly address
this last Thursday on my video I made a
comment that said like I wasn't a girl
and a lot of you thought that was a very
transphobic comment and I'm very very
sorry there was no ill intention behind
it and I of course don't have those
opinions or thoughts or any of those
beliefs and I just want you all to feel
that you were wonderful and so I'm sorry
Becca can ôt you person to person to
person Becca can out see more like Becca
can you not you hear that noise you
would everyone to feel what it's like to
be grace Helbig scratch here's your
chance to live that dream yeah it was
pretty accurate representation of being
my crotch except it's really good that
you can't feel temperature or sweat
levels through YouTube because it's like
a Russian bathhouse down there it's a
little of love of 30 men what stop
talking out loud hemp in new person to
person to person hemp ever like that
sounds like a candy from the future yeah
boys I fear for your liver you can't
spend a liver without river and
and vile and it's always about education
here on its grace well there you go
that's all for talking back to you today
I hope that you have enjoyed your time
here don't forget to go to camp Takota
comm and buy your own copy of camp
Takota I think you'll really like it and
we're all super excited about it also
don't forget that you can come to sue
Mabry and I if you live in the Boston
area we'll be doing a show there on
March 15th don't hold me to that date
just look all the right information will
be down there so just look down there we
would love to see you guys we're doing a
live show in a really big theater we
really want to fill it with all of you
and we're excited about it I'm going to
leave now hey guys okay I forgot to
mention this because if you watch
youtube videos you know that audible.com
is just you know all up in everyone's
business and guess what that bandwagon
just rolled by my house and I leaped
onto it and I tried to claw my way up
and then I fell a little bit and they
felt bad for me so they stopped the
bandwagon and let me just get on like a
normal person instead of trying to jump
from the road very hard to jump on a
moving object from the road I've tried
with many a men I am also working with
audible.com which is a downloadable book
thing right the how specific is that
audiobook so you can download and they
give me a unique URL which is
audible.com slash grace and you get your
first audio book for free I don't like
reading you don't like read well you
probably do you a lot of you are so much
better than me by the time you watch
this video I won't be on a plane and I
plan on listening to a book because I've
been listening to the same four songs on
my music device if you guys are
interested in all in listening to books
because the future is now go to
audible.com slash Grice get the first
one free or don't
if you didn't want it you could have
stopped this video by now